(upbeat music)
- We're gonna be talking about something
that might make you
feel a little squeamish.
- Everybody needs to be honest about it.
- Sex after babies!
- We have a special
guest filming us today.
(Kristin groaning)
- So guess what?
- I'm so scared.
- We just wanna warn you
and warn everyone else
that it might get a little raw.
- Like my ladybits after I gave birth.
Here's something you need to
know about sex after babies.
Whether or not your doctor
communicates this to you,
six weeks is the standard
that you should be waiting.
- Six weeks, but I'll tell you
even beyond six weeks, man.
- Oh my god, no.
When I got the all clear from the doctor,
I did not come home and jump in the sack.
- It'll be six more months.
Six more months, sorry, honey.
- It's like the groundhog, basically.
Plus, I'm doubting Phil
didn't see vaginas yet.
Six more weeks of vagina winter.
- Ochi, how long did you wait to have sex
after your first baby?
- I waited a while, I
waited about three months.
My OBGYN terrified
the shit out of me about having sex.
In one of our visits, she was
like, "Ochi, you need to know
"that you're gonna need a lot of lube.
"Then, when you think
you've had enough lube,
"put another bottle on."
I was like, "Wait, what?"
- What was your lube bill?
- Our first night, we
used some novelty lube
that we got at my bachelorette party.
It was his and hers warming,
but not the brand-name stuff, guys, no.
- Kirkland brand lube.
- It was like brand X lube.
It lit us on fire.
It literally burned, it burned both of us,
it was fucking horrendous.
- What does sex after baby feel like?
- Virginity.
- Is it virginity in that your
husband is also bad at sex?
Or is it just the tightness?
- No, yeah.
- It's the tightness
I always thought that
after you had a baby,
your vagina was supposed
to be this giant, big cave.
Vagina flapping in the wind.
- Like a parachute?
- Yes.
(Ochi and Morgan laughing)
What, you don't want to see this?
- It's not like that.
- No, it's not, that's my point.
I was so afraid that it
was gonna be like that,
but it's not.
- I just felt like, "Can
everybody stop needing
"something from my body for a minute?"
You obviously married this person,
or you've chosen to have a child with them
and maybe live together,
and you want them to
feel happy and satisfied.
- You want to please your partner,
but it's not pleasing for you.
Where is that line?
- Everybody's frustrated.
You're frustrated 'cause it hurts,
you don't even want to go there.
They come near you and
you're just like, "Ah!"
and you don't want to be like that.
You want to be loving to them.
I think it's super important that,
a lot of women have
babies and feel pressure
to get back in the sack
with their partner.
It really is about you feeling
confident and comfortable
in your body, you gotta be ready.
It can hurt, so don't rush into it.
You can also hurt yourself
if you have sex too early,
because it's a big fucking
open wound in your uterus
where your placenta used to be.
- How long before all the
sex stuff is back to normal?
- It wasn't back to normal
until I stopped breastfeeding.
- How long was that?
- I breastfed for a year.
- I'm gonna say a year.
It really wasn't back to normal,
but it's better now.
Kristen?
- Yeah, what's up?
- What do you think, you
ready to have a baby?
- No, pass, hard pass.
Cancel my subscription.
I cannot accept this award,
I'm washing my hair that day.
Is that enough excuses?
- That's good.
If I don't scare someone
out of having children
every single day, it's
like I haven't lived.
- Alright, thanks for watching.
- If you're a mom, go have
sex, but use a lot of lube.
If you're not a mom, don't have sex,
because you'll become one.
(cheerful music)